Alright guys, so here is an example number two for using the silver bullet with bias
So in the 15 minutes as you can see we have taken out this external right and we took this out at
845 but we have our draw on look really still intact
So let's go to the one minute time frame here and let's wait for that 10 o'clock time to hit
So we're gonna wait for that
Okay, so over here
This is when the clock hits 10, right? We have the 10 here
We have the shift in the marker structure as well
We have it here as well, right? We filled in this fairly gap
So now we only have this fairly gap left. This is our draw on liquidity, right? So our entry is gonna be off this fairly gap
or the 0.5 level of this fairly gap, right and
if I play this through you can see that the take profit was hit and
From there onwards, I don't know what price does. I don't have to think about it. My target is hit
I have sculpted out the silver bullet right one to one or one to one point five or one to two
Is what I should suggest?
So you could have easily gone on that by going long here is putting your stop here and then targeting this
so
Just go and experiment with this. It's very very powerful and maybe that can become your model
I don't know but
It's really up to you and I'm showing the things that work. So good luck. We're using that. So let's move on to the last
Lecture guys, I'm gonna teach you how you can use proper risk management to pass your prop from challenges
So see you guys in the next one